i don't remember where i got them from
but uh these are the bugatti frames
bugatti you know the bugatti way
what up gq is mr kid and you're watching
on the rocks
this pendant right here is um
rich forever my label i got this from
waffy
rose gold
with the white gold in the middle
with baguettes
i think this was like
75
everybody on rich forever has this you
know i'm saying pendant it's probably
not it's not the same size but a little
smaller but everybody got one you know i
started the label
i didn't have any artists at first
really i just wanted to
to start something of my own
back then went out something that i
could run myself you know saying i
wanted to be the boss
and then
somebody told me about dex my boy grams
told me about famous dicks
and after he told me about him i just
started seeing him on the ground all the
time
so then you know i signed him
and you know that's that was the
beginning of it right there
we always forever ever
this is why iran
young rich nation
um the migos label it's my family so i
was on the way to a concert
and it was like a two-hour drive from
atlanta to i think it was like alabama
or something and one of my friends had
uh the migo city and they were playing
like the whole ride down there and i was
like this is fire like who was this he
was like this amigos
and then i looked on the back of the cd
and had a number to um dj ray g
which was the dj at the time
so i called the dj i actually knew him
i'm like yo
i want to link up with amigos like like
let's put some music together or
something and he was like dope let's do
it
so later on at night
i actually was going to a club
in atlanta so when i got there and i was
about to walk in the club i seen ray g
and amigos right in front
like
the same night
so
we linked up
you know what i'm saying and then like
the next day after that i went over to
cleveland crib and we made a song
called
wiring that they put on the album so
like that's pretty much where it came
from
that way
it was the lingo that i started
it's one piece that i think
i think waffy made this from atlanta
crayola got a similar chain too you know
we we started that so
that way like the money weight runs
forever away we started the slang that
way and
everybody still uses it today but they
use it in other contexts like
money way or
bank way young thing so we started the
whole way with that one
favorite piece i got right here is
probably the jesus piece right here it
was made by elliot it's 75 000 for um
just for the tron
that's pretty dope
what was your inspiration for thinking
about that probably coming in jesus
peace
[Music]
musicians and producers have it too so
it's pretty cool
[Music]
this one i usually wear with um
this right here with this fishbowl piece
like this
i think this was like
30 25 30. whatever
i got this from waffy if y'all ever seen
the jeweler named waffy from atlanta i'm
the first person to put him on i was in
i was in the mall one day
just about to get some change like some
regular gold rope chains
and then i copped a few
i went back to the studio and quavo and
take off everybody's like yo where you
get that from
i told them
and then they went down there
and then after they went down there p
qcp
and the whole qc went down there and
then a whole bunch of athletes went down
there and then a whole bunch of
everybody you know i'm saying but it
started with me
the first person to come in there
and i said let me get one of them go
rope change what i'm saying
so really well if you're watching this
you owe me a percentage of yo don't
forget don't think i forgot all them
folks coming by and you owning it
[Music]
this right here is the big boy cuber
i wear this on my um
i probably seen the piece that i got
that spins it's like a world it's a like
a big globe
it's i broke it um it's in the fix right
now but this is
the cubing for it this was like
95 000.
it's about elliot
i think india got the best diamonds you
know
i'd rather
go to elliot and get it right the first
time
i ain't can't cop no [ __ ]
i'm not even going to get
yeah this is the um
the bracelet part it says rich on the
lock
um
i think this was like another
45
so this is like a set i bought it all at
the same time this this and then the
spinning globe
piece so it really means a lot to me
like one of my bigger chains
[Music]
these are just a few of my rings like
there's a star ring i got from icebox
these two rings i got from waffy i
usually be wearing like the whole hand
my pinky ring is [ __ ]
missing the diamond
so
i had to wear in the shop and it feels
weird wearing three rings i usually like
wearing four of them [ __ ]
i had a star ring that it was like a
pinky ring it was like just a star and i
was performing
and i was so lit i was hyped i threw a
bottle of water in the crowd
when i threw the ball of water i seen my
ring flying in the air now you could
imagine me
i would just be like
but the ring flew in the crowd and it
was like it's gone it's like deep in the
middle of the crowd i don't think they
even realized it
until like after and then after
everybody left it was it wasn't there so
that's one piece that i wish i never
lost
i really i'd really be losing a lot of
grills i had a baguette set of grills
like rose gold with top and bottom
baguettes i lost it and i lost the
bottom for this so this is just like the
top
about johnny rank i'm worried a lot
because i made my make me talk weird and
funny like this
looks nice all right
this is the paddock
right here you can't even find this if
you wanted to you can't even buy the
sequence it's like
gone the price keep going up on it i
think it's worth like 200 now
i got like a ton of watches and richard
mills and like i got another paddock
that's worth like 300. i made a psa to
everybody throw away
your diamond watches everybody pull out
the plane watches because they hold
value
you know what i'm saying i see a lot of
people you know i'm saying following
what i said i feel like i got a whole
wave in this jury for sure
[Music]
i feel like our generation really made
it popular and they're bringing like the
jewelry the flexing i know there's
people who did it before us but we was
really like breaking the knob on it you
know what i'm saying so now you see
everybody wearing jury so it's kind of
like it's they really it's kind of like
late it's like
i kind of feel like oh it's cool now
everybody got dreary but it's like
what makes you stand out that's what i'm
saying like
yo what's up it's richard kidd i
appreciate y'all for checking out my
jewelry collection with gq i'll see you
all next time on another set